welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and if the
Sounion disney deal has got you feeling
like you're caught in a web well things
just got a lot more complicated with the
reveal at spider-man aka Tom Holland was
originally meant to have a cameo in
venom this news came directly from
collide alive who when discussing the
Disney and Sony deal brought up the fact
that Tom Holland was originally meant to
appear at some point in venom however
Mickey Mouse stepped in last minute and
made the studio remove the clip as it
didn't coincide with their vision of the
MCU and at this point they wanted the
characters to remain as separate as
possible I'll play the clip now to give
you full context before we break it down
but yeah it's very interesting because
it's benefiting both of us in the long
run and actually it's benefiting Sony
too because people saw it venom because
there was rumors Tom Holland was right
and I'll tell you the truth Tom Holland
did film a scene for venom I found this
out so nice timing Marvel saw the movie
and saw that it was like take him out
take the scene out so Tom Holland did
Peter Parker was in venom not spider-man
Peter Parker but I I can't I can tell
you that Jon Schnepp told me the same
thing yep
while he even said it so on on air at
one point that he knew someone that
Holland had shot something they were
gonna they were gonna it was gonna be in
the movie and then when it didn't happen
I guess that never happened but then it
just looks like air they thought they
pulled it but the okay so some pretty
reliable sources with this information
Jon Schnepp rest in peace of course was
a huge comic book fan who created the
death of Superman lives and I pretty
much take that at their word now what it
shows is that Sony had been trying to
connect the two franchises for a long
time and that Disney sort of picked up
on this and realized that venom may in
fact cause problems for them down the
line with a granting Sony the
opportunity to go off and build their
own spider-verse
as venom wasn't really overseen by
though we do have confirmation that they
did step in at some point to help with
the editing of the film which is why
foggy wanted to produce a credit and
Disney wanted more than 5% it's clear
that they did have some involvement
I think Disney and Marvel are very
protective of their franchise and they
probably thought that the inclusion of
venom may cause some issues and perhaps
not be the way that they wanted to
handle a character's origin story as it
wasn't really tied to spider-man who is
integral to Venom's creation venom did
go on to make a lot of money and I do
agree with the Collider panel that some
of this was garnered by rumors of an
appearance by hollandaise the film
whilst it was panned quickly actually do
quite like venom except for like the
lobster scene maybe like like why did
why did he eat a full lobster anyway
other than that it's an enjoyable film
in my opinion a thing that in hindsight
maybe if Disney had let Sony include the
spider-man scene that it may have
actually helped to tie the universes
together in a way that would make it
harder to dismantle in contract
negotiations though it would have also
granted Sony the opportunity to break
off and do their own thing which they
have the potential to though as of now
apparently negotiations are still
ongoing either way it's very interesting
and pretty much confirms that Sony were
always planning to bring these two
together and who knows if Sony do decide
to split with the character that we may
indeed see Holland pop up in venom 2
what's actually really weird about all
this is that I was rewatching infinity
war yesterday just before the UK release
of Avengers endgame on blu-ray and
spider-man in the introduction is of
course coming back from a field trip so
this could have explained why it was all
the way out in San Francisco which is
where venom was set at the point of
Venom's release however infinity war had
of course happened so that probably
would have needed to be some reckoning
in order to have the character in the
film due to his death at the end this is
all extremely interesting though and I
really would have loved to have seen the
character pop up in the movie and wonder
if we will ever get this scene in
sequels but obviously loved hear your
thoughts on the scene and if you would
have liked to have seen it as well
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown on
the reports that Sony and Disney are
still in negotiations and how spider-man
may still be connected to the MCU even
if the companies fall apart would you be
linked
at the end I got over everything you
need to know about the current standing
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you're interested in the sony and disney
deal you want to come talk to me about
movies TV shows games and comic books
and you can follow me on twitter
definition YT it's the best way to get
in touch with me and is the perfect
place to suggest new videos and content
so hopefully I see you over there after
this well so just want to let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
John wig 3 on blu-ray and all you have
to do to be in with the chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the venom scene
in the comment section below the one is
gonna be chosen on September the 10th in
the blue arrow be shipped out from then
to ever get surprised so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition that you've been
the best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
Oh